- I guess like being like
out here, like in Skid Row
you hear everyone's story and you know
everyone's been molested,
everyone's been abused.
Everyone's been, you
know, domestic violence.
I mean, there's these things that become
like a way of life and so normal
but they really do, you know,
they really mess you up.
You know, they really like, yeah.
I know that from all these
things that I've gone through
in my life, I know that
I'm a broken person.
And because I don't choose to get help,
I stay running from it, you know?
- [Interviewer] All right, Samantha,
tell me where you grew up.
- [Samantha] I grew up in Riverside,
moved to the Coachella Valley,
like the lower desert when I was 14,
and came out here to LA four years ago.
- [Interviewer] And you grew up
with both parents, one parent?
- I was back and forth
between my mom and my dad
like my whole life, but my
parents divorced when I was five.
So yeah, like I was between my mom,
my dad up until I was 18,
like back and forth, back and forth.
And then my childhood was
pretty like consistent
with like that of an addict.
I was molested by my
babysitter when I was seven.
- A male or female babysitter?
- A female. I didn't even tell my mom
until like two years ago.
- It happen more than once?
- Yeah. It was like a consistent thing
that happened for awhile.
I kind of thought, I
think back and I noticed
like a lot of things in my
childhood were, you know
like weren't supposed to happen, you know?
But I, I got involved with
somebody when I was 14.
I got pregnant with that person.
And by the time I was
18 and he was like 19
he ended up having to serve six years
for great bodily injury that
he, he nearly killed me.
So like abusive relationships.
Yeah. That was just the first one.
Yeah, I had, I had a couple and then
and then like verbal,
verbally abusive, more
like the mental and
emotional abuse was probably
more damaging than anything.
Like, I mean, like I look back now
and it really took a toll on me, you know?
Yeah.
- Do you think any of them might've come
from the relationship you
have with your parents?
Like your dad? Was he like that?
- My dad is very like withdrawn.
He kind of, he told me
a couple of years ago
that he's pretty much accepted
the fact that I'm like
I'm out here and I could possibly die.
But I mean at this point I'm doing like
what could kill a person
like 20 times that fentanyl a day.
Like, and that's just
to say, well, you know
so he means right, but it's
kinda hard, you know, my dad
it's hard to hear that from you dad.
I mean, my mom has passed away
two and a half months ago.
And so just running and gunning out here.
- When did you get first
started with drugs?
- I was 14. I tried heroin.
- Heroin at 14?
- Yeah. Try that first and
then ecstasy and like cocaine.
And I had like my phases
with, with all the drugs.
Like I did it with, with my friends.
I thought it was like,
it was, it was cool.
And I just kind of went like
all my friends went this
way and I like veered
Right. Like, or left.
Yeah. I went, all my friends right now
are actually getting married
and like buying houses and stuff.
And I'm like,
- Living on the street?
- yeah, skid row.
- And what do you do for money?
- Well, to say, like to say,
I haven't like done a date
before I'd be lying, but
fortunately, like right now, I
I I'm in a situation where, I mean
I guess all of us women
out here, like we, like
we use our bodies to get,
you know what I mean?
Like in one way or another
we use our bodies to get what we need.
And I mean, fortunately I
don't have to sleep around
but you know, it's like
a game we play, you know
- It's a luxury that
women have and men don't.
I see the guys recycling,
but if they had you guys out
- Pretty much.
Yeah.
- And you have crazy stories
about any on the street?
- Hmm Hmm.
Yeah. Well, I mean like, okay,
well, I'll tell you like what
like a normal day, like
in skid row, like sure.
One day I was like, well, I was walking
up and I was walking up
seventh and I saw like a lady.
She, they, they use the fire
hydrant and to get the water
you know, like to, to
bathe and whatever else.
But she was like bathing
in the fire hydrant.
And like, I mean, it's just
it's so it's like so crazy down here.
And like, I think
like all the crazy that's
going on around you, like
that's what takes you out
of, you know, your reality?
Like, that's how, I mean
that's how I'm able to stay out here.
Like, you know, everyday
and not, not think about
you know what I mean?
Like what, I'm, what I'm running from.
It's, there's so much
going on and it's normal.
- How much
of your predicament now you
think is a product of your job?
- I have to say, Oh man,
I have to say a lot.
Like, I was really spoiled when
I was little, I was spoiled.
I grew up like really entitled and I mean
I didn't have to want for
anything, but there was like, my
my parents would like
kind of just shut the door
and like leave me in my
own devices, you know?
So I didn't get like a lot
of like the nurturing and
you know, I just, like, I
remember my, I remember a lot
of my childhood, my parents
were suicidal, like depressed.
Like, so I think that, like
that when I grew up like
like get even an adult,
that's how I learned.
I learned to do that.
You know what I mean?
Like I tried to kill myself
when I was 15, you know?
And I mean, I really tried to kill myself.
Like I wasn't, I took like a,
a bunch of different pills.
Like how did I took one
more, probably different kind
of pill, the paramedics said
that I was going to die.
If you said I would've died for sure.
But I didn't, I was on a 50, two 50.
I've had like three of those, you know
just at one point I had
three years clean, you know
I was like doing a program
and a narcotics anonymous.
I am, I ended up getting pregnant
with the person that I
was with at the time.
And I, it resulted in like an ectopic.
So I had to get surgery
and I've been loaded since
- So you have no kids?
- I have one daughter.
She's she's 10. My brother's raising her.
Yeah, my brother and his, his wife.
- And what, how much do
you spend on the fentanyl?
- It's $150 a day.
Yeah. $150 a day.
- Can you use it multiple
times throughout the day?
- Pretty much all. I mean all day, like if
I mean all day, if I
could, you know, but yeah.
As much as I can is like,
it's a different kind of
demon. It's not like heroin.
It's like worse.
It's like, yeah, there's
no, there's a bigger desire
stronger desire to get it and to get like
to fix and all that.
And his Hunt's harder to do.
Like, it's just weird.
It's hard to fine.
You know, it's, it's, it's weird.
There's like a little subculture,
little fentanyl, you know
a group or whatever.
Yeah. It's, it's, it's
all part of downtown LA.
I live in skid row, federal life,
- How old are you?
- 27. I got here when I was 24.
- And do you have of your family?
- If I chose, if I chose to.
Yeah. Like they, they will
still talk to me, you know
it's the idea is just put
put down the needle and like,
you know, agree to treatment
and then I can, you know, step
in everybody's life again.
So I guess I'm choosing this.
- Yeah. I mean, what I see from talking
to hundreds of hundreds of
people is whatever happened
to you as a child, kind
of set that mindset where
you believe you deserve the
crap you're going through.
And until you fix that, you
can get clean and you can move
to Beverly Hills and you
can do whatever you want.
And you'll end up back
here until you can fix
that mindset that makes you
believe you deserve this.
Because so many people I talk to think
that this is where they belong.
They love it here. This
is where they belong.
- Well, I was sweeping the, the
like the little area in front of the tent.
And, and I'm like, this is
like, I feel like it's normal.
It's totally normal for me.
Like, I'm just sweeping the gutter.
Like, and people are probably driving by
like taking pictures.
Like it's I don't
I don't know anything about
this right now. Its weird.
- I look at you, you're
beautiful young girl.
You can easily clean up
in about an afternoon
get a haircut, do your nails or whatever.
And you could be living in
Beverly Hills or whatever.
No one would even
- Oh, see, that's where it's like weird
because I don't feel like
I've been in there at all.
I feel like I, we were
comfortable here than there.
- And that's really the problem.
Right? It's not the drugs,
it's not the homelessness.
- It's not them, its me.
- Your belief that you deserve this
- And that this is normal.
Like, this is okay.
- Yeah. You, you think this is okay.
And that's why I'm down
here documenting this.
Cause I'm like, this is up and.
I can't believe anybody
could tolerate that.
So these people actually
you're attracted to it
So you can get off the drugs on your life
but you'll end up back here.
- No kidding. Yeah.
Cause it's, it's, it's,
it's just all too easy.
This is it.
I like that one better.
That was good.
Y'all meet me again.